j'accueille eléonore sinoquet de la
rédaction de tv 78 bonsoir en ça avec
vous on va parler musique des rumeurs il
y en a eu pendant les 28 ans de carrière
de daft punk mais cette fois ci
l'annoncé bien réel le groupe français
de musique électronique le plus célèbre
au monde a annoncé sa séparation hier
lundi alors parmi les rumeurs les plus
célèbres celle d'un duo casqué qui
viendrait de versailles pour les daft
punk est ce réellement le cas et je ne
rends pas dit gregory les bugs sont
malheureusement pas originaire de
versailles on aurait pourtant été get
lucky qui soit yvelinois et comme ils
sont évidemment inimitable le duo a
annoncé sa séparation en grande pompe il
a publié une vidéo sur sa chaîne youtube
ces images titré épilogue montre l'un
des deux hommes robot se faisant sauter
sous les yeux de l'autre de leur vrai
nom thomas bangla bangalter pardon 46
ans et guy manuel de homem christo 47
ans sont vous l'avez rappelé gregori
connu heureux d'évoquer ce sont même les
français les plus connus du monde en
musique électronique et donc vous le
confirme et ne sont pas de chez nous non
cette rumeur alors à coller à la peau
pendant des années et l'on pouvait
facilement en vrai dire se faire duper
d'abord par wikipedia moteur de
recherche où tout le monde peut se créer
une fiche d'information alors pas sur la
fiche des daft punk mais sur celle du
lycée hoche à versailles
il y figurait comme anciens élèves mais
ce n'est pas du tout le cas
en revanche daft punk sonné certains
membres du groupe français phoenix par
exemple qui ont eux ont bien étudié au
lycée hoche
ils font d'ailleurs tous partie du
courant musical la french touch avec le
groupe air également originaire de
versailles est d'ailleurs dans une
interview au magazine télérama en 2013
thomas bangalter déclarait je cite et
puisqu'on parle de wikipédia si vous
pouviez préciser que nous ne sommes
absolument pas de versailles versailles
j'ai dû y mettre les pieds quatre fois
dans ma vie
ensuite le nom c'est aussi une histoire
de localisation d'entreprise qui a pu
tromper son monde un petit peu tout à
fait le dio casque et posséderait deux
entreprises
f musique et daft tracks et ils sont
situés je vous le donne en mille
9 rue de versailles sauf que cette rue
elle est située à marnes-la-coquette
dans les hauts-de-seine
enfin ce qui pourrait une nouvelle fois
trompé bien que tout de même très
alambiquées le réalisateur du clip de
leur fameuse chanson run the world qu'on
a entendu juste à l'instant michel
gondry est lui même originaire de
versailles dont grégory one more time
non daft punk n'est pas originaire de
versailles
merci lots nord pour cette fin de
journal en musique s'il n'y avait qu'une
chose une dernière chose à dire parce
que toutes les bonnes choses ont une fin
on leur souhaite pour leurs futurs
projets voilà c'est en musique que l'on
referme ce journal merci aux normes